foreign
Douglas I'm a producer here at overheard
and today we've got something special
for you part one of our four-part series
focusing on music exploration and black
history it's called the soul of Music a
National Geographic explorers will be
sitting down with some of our favorite
musicians to discuss how history and the
natural world inspires their art and
Adventures today singer and songwriter
Rhiannon giddens chats with Explorer
Aaliyah Pierce Rhiannon is a co-founder
of the old time String Band the Carolina
Chocolate Drops she's a two-time Grammy
award winner in 2022 she won best folk
album for they're calling me home and
she's also a banjo and fiddle player
my name is Rhiannon giddens and I am a
musician and kind of a performing
historian sort of an armchair historian
I suppose
nowadays Rhiannon lives in Ireland but
she was born and raised in North
Carolina and growing up she was
surrounded by the sounds of Bluegrass
folk and country music
genres that all prominently feature the
banjo and their sound
it sounds like this that backing track
you're hearing right now and it sort of
looks like a guitar but with the
circular drum like body
for a host of reasons that we'll get
into these genres and subsequently the
banjo have stereotypically been
considered white people music
Rhiannon is biracial her dad is White
and her mom is black so she says she
sometimes felt like an outsider in folk
in bluegrass music but when she started
researching the history of the banjo she
found herself more firmly connected with
her Roots being a musician from North
Carolina that was investigating the
music of North Carolina uh
gave me a place as a mixed person that I
hadn't really felt like I had see the
banjo has a complicated history it's
descended from gourd bass instruments
that were brought over to the Americas
by enslaved Africans it's created in the
Caribbean and it travels up to
the United States with enslaved people
and becomes a staple of of life
this week Rhiannon sits down with
National Geographic Explorer and spoken
word poet Aaliyah Pierce to discuss the
origins of the banjo and how history
inspires Rihanna's music
Aaliyah was a contributor to the
award-winning National Geographic
podcast Into the Depths which followed
Explorer Tara Roberts and other black
scuba divers across the world as they
search for buried shipwrecks from the
transatlantic slave trade when they sat
down to talk Alia told Rhiannon she had
written a poem inspired by her music and
the banjo
I'm a poet music is a big key influence
for my writing
um and so I actually wrote a piece
inspired by the banjo oh and I dedicate
this poem to the work that you do
because I was actually listening to a
lot of your music as I was writing this
um so this is called they're calling me
home
calling me home to Sawmill tune history
conjure ancestral spirits to strum Soul
sounds to help folks remember this body
of Music how our bodies are music how
our hearts cultivated the rich soil of
country how the centuries of Blues were
also a blessing how the picking of the
five strings reaches Hallelujah High
vibrations they're calling me home to
bridge the truth and transform the tone
of what black Revolution and Global
Connection means to banjo
[Music]
love it thank you so good oh my God
I hope I got some of that language right
Hallelujah
[Laughter]
this is overheard at National Geographic
a show where we eavesdrop on the wild
conversations we have here at naggio and
follow them to the edges of our big
weird beautiful world
more with Rhiannon and Aaliyah after the
break
but first feel your curiosity with a
free one-month trial subscription to
naggio digital you'll have unlimited
access on any device anywhere ad free
with our app that lets you download
stories to read offline explore every
page ever published with a century of
digital archives at your fingertips
check it all out for free at Nat geo.com
Explore More
[Music]
all right Rhiannon I want to kind of get
into the conversation of the banjo a bit
the banjo has such an interesting
history could you tell me just a little
bit about that
so the banter's true Origins are you
know recently becoming more and more
sort of Center Stage when you talk about
um uh the history of American music and
that's great because for a very long
time there was this assumption that the
banjo was about the widest instrument
that you could possibly imagine you know
that it was invented in the hauler and
and played by Hillbillies you know which
in and of itself is a stereotype and in
actuality it is actually a an instrument
created by the African diaspora it's
important to say that it's not African
it is actually an instrument the African
diaspora if you want to say
African-American in terms of the
broadness of South America all the way
up to North America and the Caribbean in
between
um but it is created by people from
Africa in the new world and so it really
is an American a Caribbean an
afro-caribbean you know a diasporic
African diasporic instrument
um and there are ancestors to the banjo
that exist all over Africa particularly
West Africa and and there's not one that
can say it is the the one ancestor it's
like there's there's loads of
instruments and and they're all in the
DNA of all the different banjos that
were sort of you know invented
um in the Caribbean and then like what
15 1600s and so it was known as a black
instrument solely for a long time and it
wasn't until the 1800s the early 1800s
that it really starts to cross over in a
way that we
know about like obviously there's a
million different interactions of people
over hundreds of years and there could
be a white person that picked up a banjo
at some point that we never knew and you
know in 1701 we don't know but we do
know in the early 1800s that's when it
really starts to migrate and Joel
Sweeney is the first white guy that we
know of to really
um to really be a banjo player a white
banjo player but before this it was
really mostly known as a black
instrument
where did this associating with
whiteness come in because as a black
artist
as a black woman artist I feel like this
disservice like I haven't known the
truth
so where did this associating with
whiteness happen
yeah I mean this is the same feeling I
had when I found out I was like what
and then immediately on the heels of
that it was like oh what else don't I
know what else haven't they told me you
know and it really kind of opened my
eyes to the idea of history as a
reflection of the time that it's written
in and not necessarily a reflection of
what actually happened
it's a long history like the idea of
history and who's writing it and what
angle are they writing it from and
so the history of the banjo really
becomes part of this mythical white
cultural identity that was really
heavily rooted in Anglo
Anglo-Saxon
ballads and also some Celtic stuff too I
mean that that
um becomes part of the picture
particularly later but in the beginning
it was really this idea of
pushing back against What was seen as
like the jungle music of like blues and
jazz people like Cecil shark come over
who's like at the musicologist from
England to collect these ballads that
they had found still surviving in the
mountains and these ballads you know
were versions of ballads that had been
you know sung in England hundreds of
years before so they were all like
freaking out like oh my gosh this is
this culture has been unadulterated
isolated in the mountains for 100 yeah
right you know there's no isolation
right there's no isolation there are
black people living in the Appalachian
Mountains right particularly up until
the Great Migration there's just all
this mixing going on but the narrative
is that it's this like pure white
identity and the banjo becomes part of
that the story of it being in black
hands is is basically erased
um black string bands are not recorded
during the beginning of the recording
industry it there was also this this
concerted effort um in the early
folk festivals and uh like fiddle
conventions this is considering that
like black people were I've been playing
fiddle and banjo for a long time and
we're really really good at it and we're
well known to be like some of the best
musicians in the area but they weren't
allowed to enter they weren't they
weren't highlighted in these festivals
and so when you go back to the beginning
of the Folk Festival movement where the
black people you know they weren't
invited
so I want to jump to kind of the
mechanics of the banjo for a second
I understand that a five-string banjo
has what's called like a drone string
what is a drone string if you could kind
of tell us
so the idea of a drone and it's in its
in lots of different kinds of uh of
Music systems all over the world like
right now
this idea that if you if you're seeing a
melody and there's a drone that's going
on it stays in the same key and it's a
real linear Melody it's not necessarily
thinking of stacking notes and creating
chords
it's like there's this underlying
um
[Music]
you can just hear that right so like
just in general that's what a drone is
and so the banjo has this short string
that you cannot fret so when you make a
note on a stringed instrument you hold
your finger down on it and it changes
the pitch right and that's how you make
all the different sounds but a drone
string on the banjo doesn't you can't do
that it just stays the same note so if
you want to change it you actually
actually have to tune it which means you
have to stop playing to do that so you
can't do that in the middle of the song
so that means you really you have to
play in one key which is very very much
as you want in a lot of different
particularly like Middle Eastern music
African music
um European music is very much based on
chords you know where you stack two or
three four notes and then you move the
motion is very um top to bottom rather
than left to right and and so the banjo
doesn't really fit in that corridal
system it's it's a it's a very much
connected to that other those other
styles in Middle East and West Africa
because it's like it itself is like
connected to this vast line of
instruments that go all the way back to
China you know through the Middle East
through Africa through you know
um the other thing that the fifth string
does is that it creates syncopation
okay because you have five strings right
so to especially in the the very old
style which is called stroke Styles claw
hammer frailing or whatever it goes all
the way back to like some playing Styles
in West Africa you know it's it's very
much the the thumb is on the fifth
string and you're striking single
strings with your with your index finger
and it just creates syncopation like you
can't it's very hard to not play with
some kind of syncopation with a string
so it is really inherent in
um and what the banjo is and what the
banjo has has uh contributed to American
music
[Music]
and then ask you about the song is
called at the purchasers option I've got
a baby
it will come the day when I'll be
weeping
but how can I love him any days
[Music]
so break this song down for me what is
it about it's part of a larger
collection of of pieces written from the
world of slavery
um from I wrote songs from slave
narratives and this one in particular
was from
the ephemera that surrounds slavery the
everyday evil the the quotidian nature
of a system that was completely hand in
glove with our how we made money
you can take my body you can take my
bones you can take my blood but not my
soul you can take my body you can take
my bones you can take my blood but not
my soul
know and so I was looking through
advertisements
for people
they were you know you put put a ad in
the paper for somebody to sell them
and this is the thing that I always want
to try to impress upon people is that
they don't understand because I didn't
understand that people were cash
black people were cash you know it's
like you can have affection for that car
and you can love that car but if you
need to pay a bill you're gonna sell
that car
and that's what happened with people it
was like oh Jill love ya but
gotta go you know and it's complicated
and I'm not you know it's not to say
that people were complete automatons but
like
that was deeply rooted in the culture
and that's what you see in the signs
that say you know slave auction or this
you know runaway ads or this kind of
thing ads for dogs that are really good
at catching slaves
this is the stuff that I started getting
into and I found this one ad about
this young woman who was for sale
um she's 22 years old and it was the end
of the ad it said she has with her
nine-month-old baby who is at the
purchaser's option
it's like what do you do with that what
do you do with that it's like it's so
epically horrific
you know that it just just the very
banal
nature of those words you know what I
mean at the purchaser's option so
I wrote a song
just to do something with that
I wrote a song about
her just trying to think of the world
that she lives in how did she
how did she survive
you know how does she get up how do you
open your eyes and decide to get up and
feed your nine month old knowing
that tomorrow they will be gone
how do you do it
this song came out of me exploring that
and trying to hold her up
and to think about her I don't know her
name I'll never know her name but
um
I know that
it took an amazing Act of courage to
face the day every day
and so just try to crawl into that
um into that space
I think that's the difficult thing about
black history in itself is that there
are so many names that are lost so many
names that have been forgotten
intentionally erased like just the even
the idea of just names so you'll never
know that name
um and so I'm wondering how did you even
find that ad
on the on the web
you know I do use a lot of my research
on on the computer because so many
things are digitized now it's a really
amazing era for as as horrific as uh
social medias and these other things it
also has allowed people like me to do
the kind of research that previously
would have been you have to be at a
university with a degree and the time to
go sit through the stacks you know
whereas I I can
visit I can visit universities virtually
and and see what they have online and so
there's a lot of these
um advertisements uh there's a lot of
there's like a whole collection of
runaway slave ads
um freedom on the move which is then you
they've been taken and made poem made
into poems and lyrics and now that's
going to be a concert of Music
um you know people are creating things
from from this and it's important
because we have so little
you know when you look at
African-American history
um we have so little and so every little
bit we have is big
and we're finding these things like
these like these runaway ads it's like
there's an incredible amount of detail
in these ads you thought that's how we
found a load of people played the fiddle
in the banjo that ran away because they
had a way to make money it's one of the
few ways that wasn't like Toten
infection
that you could actually make a living
and um so it's important to not discard
these things and to look at them through
the lens of we know that these there are
white people putting the stuff in the
paper for reasons that are not great but
we need to take it and turn it around
and go this is information and and the
idea of the names you know I've tried to
address that where I can so the my song
that's from a slave narrative uh from
the from the book called the slaves War
by Andrew Ward
um I wrote a song called Julie and in
that it's a conversation between a a
black woman and the woman who
thinks that she owns her and so Julie
has a name and the mistress does not
and that that was important for me and I
do it wherever I can I even tried in my
Opera Omar I tried I tried to give all
the white people like non-names and they
said you can't do that because some of
these people are historical and they
actually existed and I was like dang it
you know so everybody got a name you got
a name and you got a name and you get a
name
um but uh you know I tried I try to
think about that where I where I can
um because it's just such a massive such
a massive thing
[Music]
I have another song that I want to play
a clip from This song is called build a
house
you brought me here
[Music]
again break this song down for me what
is it about
um this song is one that I wrote
uh in during the lockdown or during the
kind of height of the pandemic and the
height of the protests after George
Floyd's murder
um and I was here in Ireland kind of
feeling very stuck you know I couldn't
get home
um I mean this is a home but it's
obviously not my birth home and I was
just feeling the The Strife that was
happening in the United States and
wanting to be I don't know abuse I found
a place to build my house build my house
build my house I found a place filled my
house since I couldn't go back home
you said I couldn't build a house
build a house
just washing all the stuff in the
commentary and trying to explain to my
children why I was crying and
I just like I got really mad I was like
what do y'all want
it brought us here you know to build
this pardon my French you brought us
here to build this stuff and now you're
mad that we're still here
you know and and it that that became the
first line you brought me here to build
your house and and it's in very very
simple valid language
um uh but I this this kind of
300 400 year history in in three minutes
um and and the big point of it was to
just
I don't know do something with all this
emotion again
you know and all the history of the the
stuff that I've read and you know it's
kind of like a 15 years of frustration
in in one song and um and Yo-Yo Ma
reached out to me the cellist uh reached
out to me it was really close to
Juneteenth and said you want to do
something for Juneteenth and I said I
just wrote the song and he said sounds
great let's do it and we did it and we
put it out there and you know it made me
feel a little bit better I don't know
you know and um it's now a children's
book
which is really exciting
um and with the beautiful artwork by
Monica makai's fabulous artist and I've
done some readings and and stuff and
it's really interesting how kids get it
you know because you might think this is
a song about slavery like oh how do you
do that and it's like
people get it kids get it they they see
what's happening oh that's not fair I'm
like yes that's exactly right that's not
fair and like that's not right and
that's not cool
and so that's been really an amazing
example to me of of how things can live
in different areas and like so many
ballads and and history songs and and
whatnot or like teaching songs they're
like a moral or a something that you can
remember because it's set to music and
it Rhymes and it's really easy to
remember and to take a song and and to
break it down and put images with it and
and then you go yeah that's what these
songs are for it's like creating a new
ballad creating new new historical songs
or something you know
um it ends with I shall not be moved I
will not be moved which I learned from a
mentor of mine the guy who really is the
reason why I'm sitting here talking to
you Joe Thompson who is uh
one of the old one of the last like
black Fiddlers of the old tradition you
know he was 86 when I met him and he is
the elder of what I do
um he's dead now but I I got a good
handful of years with him and um
he taught he taught us the song I shall
not be moved which is a very common song
that's been used for the Civil Rights
Movement but I always think of him he
just like had lived his life
played his fiddle
was in his community
and you know there's nothing people
you know so
when I sing that and I get to that last
part I think of him I was like he
created a life
he lived a good life and
he thrived in in a soil you know that he
was trying he was planted into his you
know his his line and why why should we
go anywhere
you know
absolutely the roots go deep it's been
it's been a few hundred years the roots
are deep
[Music]
you recently wrote and composed the
Opera Omar about a West African man who
was brought to America as a slave tell
me a little bit about Omar what inspired
you to write an opera about him I was
commissioned to write Omar by the folks
at the spoletto festival in Charleston
I'd never heard of him I was a North
Carolinian born and raised never heard
of Omar like when like legit one of our
most famous enslaved people and I'd
never heard of him I was just livid and
these folks asked me to write an opera
about Omar bin Saeed and I was like you
better go ahead I you know Omar was a
quranic scholar I was 37 when he was
sold and he has to start completely over
in this new world that's full of
violence and nobody speaks his language
nobody worships the way that he worships
the God that he worships and you know
again how do you
how do you get through that how do you
claim a life within that and and how did
he stay true to his religion and you
know and write his autobiography in
Arabic 20 years after he landed
I felt a lot of responsibility I still
do very very much wanting to figure out
what is my lens here what is my journey
as a
I'm not Muslim I'm not West African I'm
not a man I don't study the Quran
there's so many things that I'm not
um and I kept having to go back to I
have to tell the story that I
can tell
um with respect and knowledge as much
knowledge as I can gain and to also
really kind of let the spirit guide me
yeah
that's
the delicious thing about being an
artist is that you can imagine
um with a cultural piece right I think
when you're a part of in some aspect a
part of the African diaspora it allows
us to imagine with this cultural
Foundation it's joyous work it's heavy
work it's again right we're going to
keep using this word complex I think
it's complex work but I think it's
beautiful that we're in a time where
we're seeing black people in the U.S
actually being involved in their own
excavation yes yes this is it it's like
it's cultural archeology
that's what we're doing and and it is
just like
you've got a field with like some
circles in it
and that's how you know it was a castle
right and you have to dig and you find
these shards and from this Shard you
extrapolate a freaking vase right which
is what they do because of the curvature
of the thing and this and whatnot and
what they know what was in the soil and
and then they find this like blue piece
of glass that obviously had to come from
like 3 000 miles away and you know it
tells you a lot about what was happening
it's the exact same thing with this
music except for we have to find the
negative space around because of course
music is here and gone
so it's like finding the the imprint
that the music left the imprint that
these lives left in in in the in these
sort of bits and pieces and it is great
to see us in there and it's the only way
forward it's the only way forward is
that we all have to be at the table it's
like it's not like just black people
should do this now it's like all of us
should do this and that there's a team
effort because it is
all of our Legacy you know and it's not
just black and white it's also red you
know it's all about Native people
talking about other immigrant
populations talking to them you know
it's just like you know the music that
was made by Armenian refugees in
California and and and Jewish folks in
New York and and Chinese people in Texas
or whatever I mean it's like
it's super
it's super beautiful
um when it comes to that kind of thing
obviously the reason why people left
isn't beautiful ever but
but you know we we as musicians as
artists as writers we find the joy
in in the Despair and that's how that's
how we keep going
musicians as being translators in some
sense either in terms of translating
history or translating emotion are they
translators
I think artists create a shortcut I
think they create an emotional Bridge
for the listener
into an emotion a thought a Feeling
and I think that it's an important job
but I but I I am very sad for the fact
that we need we need that because what
it means is that people don't create
those emotional bridges for themselves
because we have de-arted
everyday life we've separated we've
commodified it the amount of people that
have come to a singing workshops that
I've given who were like yeah I was told
I couldn't sing I was told I couldn't
play I shouldn't make music because I
wasn't very good at it leave it to the
professionals and that stuff like kills
my heart
it kills my heart because
we don't you don't need to go to the
movies and the concerts and to watch TV
all the time if you're in the act of
making art in your own life more you
know it's not to say that there are some
people who are really good
at making art and yes pay them to do
something that you were never going to
be able to do and you go enjoy that and
that's awesome but like
the everyday magic of singing a song or
playing a tune or writing a poem or you
know writing a story just to do it not
to make money at it but just to do it
that's what we're missing I feel and I
think that we need more of that in you
know put the music back in the schools
turn the TV off and and go learn how to
play a really simple tune really
crappily on the piano you know and have
to be awesome but it just needs to bring
people Joy you know
um so anyway I'm a real proponent of
like make us less necessary
you know
that's a mic drop moment there
that was Explorer Aaliyah Pierce in
conversation with musician Rhiannon
giddens if you like what you hear and
you want to support more content like
this please rate and review us in your
podcast app and consider a National
Geographic subscription that's the best
way to support overeird go to Nat
geo.com Explore More to subscribe learn
more about Rhiannon and her music the
Opera Omar and her children's book build
a house at her website
rhianningiddens.com that's spelled r h i
a n n o n g i d d e n s and you can
follow her on Twitter at Rhiannon
giddens you can follow National
Geographic Explorer Aaliyah Pierce at
her Instagram at Leah S Pierce let's
build
[Music]
a-l-y-e-a-s-p-i-e-r-ce that's all in
your show notes right there in your
podcast app this week's overheard
episode is produced by me Kyrie Douglas
our senior producers are Brian Gutierrez
and Jacob Pinter our senior editor is
Eli chin our manager of audio is Carla
Wills who edited this episode our
executive producer of audio is davar
ardellon
our photo editor is Julie Howe Ted
Wood's sound design this episode and
hansdale Sue composed our theme music
the solo music series is produced in
collaboration with National Geographic
music
special thanks to Hannah Grace Van
Cleave Jennifer Stillson and Brittany
Greer this podcast is a production of
National Geographic partners the
National Geographic Society committed to
illuminating and protecting the wonders
of our world fund the work National
Geographic Explorer Aaliyah Pierce
Michael Tribble is a vice president of
integrated storytelling Nathan lump is
National Geographic's editor-in-chief
thanks for listening and see you next
time
thank you
[Music]